what's going on everyone i have been
known as the partnership
killer uh and so what i want to share to
you with you today is something that
comes up on
i mean every week on coaching calls with
uh you know younger entrepreneurs
younger business owners not even younger
just
other business owners who aren't doing
as much and who want more
and the question is usually one of two
things first is
you know what should our roles be within
our partnership and then
two what do you think of partnerships in
general and so what i want to do is
share with you a couple of
hard hard hard earned lessons uh that i
have
and so first right off the bat i i think
i counted i have nine
failed partnerships um and so i just
want to say right
right before you even get going i could
be the problem with the partnerships
right if if you have that many failed
partnerships then it's probably
you you were the common theme so i will
say that first and foremost up front
um that being said i think the reason
that many of those partnerships fell
they all happened you know
almost concurrently i just did
partnership after partnership for
partnership because i heard it's like
you gotta find good partners
um but what i didn't understand was how
it actually needed to be structured and
how it worked and so
there's uh there's there's a few pieces
of that
the first is if you're just starting out
i think that for the most part
it's better to not have partners um and
that is because
usually it's like you and a buddy and
you're like hey we like hanging out we
should go into business together
when really you're doing that for the
emotional need to be satisfied to have
somebody to talk to and share the
experience with but not because it's a
good business decision
and the only reason for you to have a
partner is because they either have
money or skills that you do not have
that is it it's the only reason money or
skills
that's it and so if you both are
entrepreneurial people and you're both
you know
love selling and love marketing you're
very promotion oriented which many
entrepreneurs are
right if that's you then
if they're that way too then one of you
is not required and you have to really
face that
so if you both like the same stuff you
both shouldn't
have your own businesses
it almost always fails like literally it
almost always fails
and so that's the first one the second
thing is that those
jump into bed together partnerships
don't have step number two which is you
don't have a contract you don't have
terms you don't have an agreement
and the reason is because you're so
afraid of like messing up the vibe we
don't operate that way
you will when it gets [ __ ] up at the
end but i'm telling you right now
i i now even when i have somebody who
approaches me and says hey like will you
take a percentage of my company can you
coach me through this blah blah
i say let's go through the lawyers first
all right because the thing is is
you get to see how this person acts
under stress because it is stressful
because inherently you're going to
disagree on things and so this is the
perfect experience like perfect time
for you to go kind of get a simulation
of that
it's like what happens if you don't want
to work and i want to work what happens
if you leave
what happens if i i don't want to do
this anymore like you have to go through
all the scenarios and get a good lawyer
and you should really have two that
represent you uh if you don't have the
money for that then
get somebody to just counsel you on you
know you can google a standard
partnership agreement
their templates are free online and you
can pay one lawyer for
one hour of of time to at least say
these are the things you should look for
now you know decide amongst yourselves
and so you can represent yourself in
your partnership you know agreement
but you have to have the agreement and
you have to spell it out in clear terms
uh because if you don't have that it's
like it's the bedrock of good
communication and
expectations right like otherwise
usually like most relationships
bit partnerships end because of unmet
and unspoken
expectations like well i thought you're
going to do this i was like well i
didn't know but no one even says that
because they can't communicate so
first is you probably shouldn't just
jump together with somebody because they
uh they're just like you if you are
going to do that then you should make
sure that you have contracts
in place and then finally what i want to
do is kind of explain to you what the
three main roles
roles that exist in a business are okay
three
the three pillars all right i want to
see if i have a tripod here
all right here we go here's my tripod
all right so there's three pillars
to every business all right the first
is acquisition which is the rainmaker or
somebody who's gonna bring in business
so that's marketing and sales
all right acquisition the money getter
all right the second
of these is the product which is what
you are actually selling
it's the fulfillment it's the service
it's the widget it's the whatever
somebody who knows
how to deliver it all right and then
third
you have the operations which is
everything else that has to happen in
the company
paying payroll paying taxes making sure
legal and contracts and
uh i.t and uh you know finance and all
like the
you know your accounting all of that
stuff hr has to happen
right and so these are the three legs of
every business now
they're not necessarily equally weighted
and that's an it's an important point
right
like a lot of times there are good
operators that you can get for
significantly less and
many times not even equity because there
are more of them
right now raid making being able to
bring in business is a very highly
valued skill in the marketplace
on the flip side having the thing the
product that you're going to sell
is also very valuable now this is why
skill stacking
is so important if you can have multiple
of these skills
then you have two or all three of the
legs right
now your these are the roles that have
to exist it doesn't mean you have to be
partners with these people
but you have to have all three of these
things for your business to stand
up and so for example within uh the
company i'll walk through my roles
within each of the companies that i own
and so uh the first is gym launch right
so in gym launch i am both the
acquisition and the product
right or that was my founding role
within the company
layla my wife runs ran all the
operations so everything else
so like i said i t billing legal uh
finance
hr all of that stuff that had to happen
she took care of
right super important but because of
that we had all three legs of the stool
and we were able to build a business
right if you're missing one of the legs
it's not going to work right and with
this is where this is really dangerous
is like a lot of the marketing people
that are in this world
are really good promoters they can get
people in they can sell them but then
they have no fulfillment they have no
thing
right and then they have no one who's
organized and so everything like
you send emails in you try and get help
and they don't respond it's because they
just don't have the other piece
i don't think it's because they're bad
intention i think just don't have the
skill and so
you have to have all three and so if
you're going to bring someone in
you you need them to have one of those
things right now you can start a
business and own all of it and just make
sure that you fill the roles of those
people
but as you're thinking through it
there's the role so if you're going to
bring partners in
in the beginning you want to be clear
about what it is that they're bringing
to the table now if they're
if they're one of those three right
then that's a clearly defined role and
then at that point that's what you can
lay out in your agreement and then you
can argue about or you know negotiate
whatever equity if you're doing this in
the beginning
but if you've already started at that
point then you can look at the three
legs of the stool
and see where where am i lacking right
and so for most of you guys who are
listening most people follow me are
on the or like the promotion side so
they like the acquisition side
then what you need to do is find a
strong operator all right and depending
on what you're selling if you know the
thing that you're selling then you can
basically be product and acquisition
and have a strong second to help you
fulfill on those things and basically
don't go to jail
right and you know get buy your taxes
and all the other stuff um
and so when i'm thinking about
partnerships and when i have you know
younger guys who are coming in
many many times after having discussions
with me and then talking to them
each other they realize that they have
the exact same role they like the same
things
and one of them is not necessary and so
they oftentimes split and that's
not a bad thing right it's better to
recognize an error early
than to recognize an error late all
right and so you may be in one of these
partnerships where you're like we gotta
both do the same thing we kind of just
overlap on everything it's like yeah
that's just two people working
the same thing um and so it's not like
you don't want to just be like oh there
here's all this work i'll do half you do
have
that's not a good partnership you have
to figure out what are the things where
i am good at what are the things you are
good at
and then we draw a line on the board and
everything on that side you own
and everything on this side i own and
i'm responsible for because if
everyone's responsible for everything no
one's responsible for anything
right and then nothing's gonna get done
and then you can never know who to blame
and someday you're like well he takes
out the trash or something i take out
the trash and we just kind of
we're just like kind of get it done type
stupid
there's no there's no big business that
works away all right and so if even if
you are small you need to start thinking
big to become big
right so you got to do the actions
before you get the results you have to
have the beliefs before you get the
outcomes
of a bigger business to become a bigger
business and the reason most businesses
stay small
is because they think small and they act
small so they stay that way because the
outcome of what they're doing
is the result of the actions they're
making which are small right and so
right now
if you're in a partnership if you don't
have a partnership you're thinking about
starting a business
i would definitely try and just acquire
the skills myself get going and then
the first hire i'm going to have is
going to be a strong operational second
all right it's the first thing i'm going
to do if you are in a partnership you
need to put all the activities
that you do on a board i do this when i
do consulting stuff
but all the activities that happen in
the business on a board if you don't
know what it is you do a time study
which means you
write down every 15 minutes what you do
in a week right because you probably
don't know because you're scattered all
over the place
so if you write it all down and you both
bring it to each other and you put it on
a whiteboard or put it on a board then
what you can do is say okay these are
all the things these are all the
activities that happen in our business
let's divide these out and say who owns
these all right and that's the very
beginning of an
organization because you are becoming
organized you are
creating roles and responsibilities you
were creating specialization of skills
which is what moved humanity forward
specialization is a good thing
right and so the very beginning you get
all of it on there and you can divide it
out and you can divide it based on the
skills of the person if you both have
the same skills then either you decide
okay well i'm going to become a
specialist in this and you're going to
become a specialist in this
or we shouldn't be doing this business
together and you should do a business
that's just like mine or or something
else and you should become and you
should be that role for that company and
you should find a second just like i
will
all right and oftentimes if you can at
least think that way
then you don't lose you don't liquidate
the most valuable thing
in the whole world which is your equity
all right because if your thing actually
does grow if your business actually does
grow
then the biggest dilution of how much
money you're going to make is that first
decision when you started when you just
decided just right off the bat to give
half of everything away all right and
i've made this mistake
nine times um and uh it took me
and you know i haven't had a partner in
four years and i've made all of the
money in my life
post partners and so um
there's also other factors you want to
look at too like what kind of you know
what kind of working schedule do you
have how much vacation time do you wanna
have
are you gonna work weekends do you work
late at night do you work in the
mornings do you expect each other to be
responsive like there's all these little
things that
you need to make sure you dial in
because if you don't it's just going to
cause trouble later and it may be hard
conversations for you now but believe me
it'll be much harder later
when the expectations are not being met
and now you have money involved
all right so anyways these are the
things i think through when i'm looking
at partners and partnerships and why
oftentimes i do break up many partners
because they don't start them for the
same
for the right reasons um and so i hope
you found this valuable
if you have a partner talk to them about
it show them this video um
and uh keeping amazing and uh lots of
love oh
total bonus um i have noticed that works
really well
so many times is married couples uh
married couples starting business
together
they already have usually differences in
skills and different dynamics
and so that usually works well usually
one of them is the more go-getter hunter
killer right you know the acquisition
side and the other person's usually the
more organized
more stable um you know more even-headed
like does all the ops in the back the
back-end stuff
right and so even just thinking about
front-end and back-end is a good way to
start and that's why i love having
married couples in general
because they almost always are
successful if they can just eliminate
those skills and they usually already
have
even even without speaking they already
unknowingly have made a lot of these
specializations that's why a lot of
times they're more successful they also
have the interpersonal
emotional uh sounding board to bounce
things off of and also
relieve some of the stress that
inevitably comes when you're when you're
running a business so
anyways hope you enjoyed the video hope
you found this valuable uh you know
share with your partner or potential
partners and uh
see in the next vid bye